New York Times bestselling author and
educator simon Sinek
gave one of the most popular TED Talks
ever nearly 50 million views online the
next talk inspires people to live their
most successful lives take a listen but
if you don't know why you do what you do
and people respond to why you do what
you do then how will anybody how will
you ever get people to vote for you or
buy something from you or more
importantly be loyal and want to be a
part of what it is what you bet you do
Sonax new book the infinite game
explains how you can achieve success by
thinking of life like a game with no end
and he joins us at the table now good
morning good morning a game with no end
life as a game that really a good idea
how does that help people so in 1986
James car so philosopher articulated
that if you have at least one competitor
a game exists and there are two types of
games there are finite games and they're
infinite games a finite game is defined
as known players fixed rules and an
agreed upon objective baseball there's
always a beginning a middle and an end
sometimes X ratings yeah but it
eventually comes to an end right an
infinite game is defined as known and
unknown players the rules are changeable
which means you can play however you
want and the objective is to perpetuate
the game so when you have a game that
has no finish line there's no such thing
as winning because we don't know what
the end is what the metrics are it's the
difference between somebody who thinks
for the finite mine and in it in mind
can you give us three different examples
of those two categories finite thinkers
do what so somebody playing with a
finite mindset is is obsessed with
winning in a game where literally
there's no finish line yeah so there's
no such thing as winning global politics
there's no such thing as winning
business no one is declared the winner
of business it doesn't exist but when we
listen to so many leaders they talk
about being number one being the best or
beating their competition no based on
what there's just no such ratings
advertising for now you'll be number one
for now yeah what's the advantage when
you shift your thinking so when you
shift your thinking to an infinite
mindset in the infinite game you're
actually playing for the game you're in
when we play with a finite mindset in an
infinite game there's a few very
predictable and consistent outcomes the
decline of trust the decline
of cooperation and the decline of
innovation which means when we play with
an infinite mindset in the infinite game
yes we'll see the increase in trust the
increase in cooperation and the increase
in the innovation is one better than the
other because I started out thinking
finite is better and then after reading
your book I'm thinking maybe infinite is
better is one better than the other
narrative not a question of better or
worse it's a question of playing with
the right mindset for the game you're
actually in so if you're playing
baseball you have to play with a finite
mindset you can't just play to improve
in baseball because the odds are you're
publicly lose by the end of the game
because it runs out so who establishes
the rules of the game the rules of the
game are the rules of the game like
there are why are we theme but life is a
game anyway I was told like this is not
a game this is your life your one and
only life well I mean it's it's a game
with a little G I mean the the most
important thing here is that we're so
obsessed with winning or losing but
really it's the journey it's the play
it's the playing of the game that's
actually more important the plays the
thing the play is the thing you do seem
to be encouraging people though to think
outside the box when I the more I read
about an infinite thinker I started
thinking maybe I'm wondering I certainly
want to be one because they do look at
things very differently they look at the
value what the value they bring and how
they want to make the world a better
indifferent place
absolutely okay it's look we can learn
to change our mindset yes and and since
I sort of started writing this book I've
learned to become much more of an
infinite thing for myself so if
something bad happens at work or
something you know that I think has set
me back or made me feel like a loser you
know I lost this I know whether it's a
piece of business or an opportunity I've
now sort of stay I remind myself and say
taken in from that mindset and I think
to myself know I'm behind I haven't lost
anything yes I'm just behind for now and
the opportunity is to improve the only
true competitor in an infinite game is
ourselves your work is also about
leadership and you say you don't have to
be in a position of authority to be a
leader I know so many people who are at
the highest levels of organizations who
are not leaders exactly they have
authority yes and we do as they tell us
because they have authority over us how
do you be a leader without authority so
a leader whether you have authority or
not whether you have rank or not is a
responsibility to see those around us
rise and so if you make the choice to
look after the person to the left of you
and the right of you you are the leader
and
every one of us can be the leader we
wish we have we got to go but I want to
say this about Simon he's described as a
visionary thinker with rare intellect I
like that about you and your mission you
say is to help build a better world
people wake up every day and inspired
safe and inspired safe at work return
home fulfilled yeah every single day I
want to be remember your club thank you
very intimate game is on sale now